joy is directed by David O'Russell and
stars Jennifer Lawrence Robert De Niro
and Bradley Cooper amongst others and is
the true story of a woman named joy who
invented a mop and is really trying hard
to sell it and just saying the plot like
that makes it seem kind of stupid I mean
it does the film injustice to describe
the plot that way because it's really an
underdog story about a woman who is
struggling to be a mother a daughter all
the difficulties that surround her life
the fact that she basically does
everything for her entire family no one
really trusts her there are good things
about this film and there are bad by far
the best aspect of this movie is
Jennifer Lawrence she remains the bright
spot of virtually every film that she's
in her performance is great she's strong
she's tough she's funny she's likable
she's vulnerable she gives all of the
well-rounded emotions that you would
expect an underdog story like this
because that's what this movie really is
it is an underdog story at its core and
you can't help but get behind that in
some cases you do want to root for
somebody who's like the everyman or
every woman in this case where the film
falters though for me is every other
character in the movie I didn't care
about any of them I mean basically
everyone except for joy feels like a
movie character we have these very
over-the-top family members who are
almost like the villains of the movie
who are constantly trying to steal her
ideas or tell her that she isn't good
enough or get in a way of her business
really the only character in the movie
that I felt attached to or that actually
felt like a human being was joy De Niro
is good in the movie as usual Bradley
Cooper is also good in the movie but
these characters don't feel like
characters to me they just feel like
people that walk in and out of the frame
and that's my biggest issue with Joy's
that I simply didn't really care about
any of the characters except for joy
herself and there are a lot of
characters in this film it also takes a
while to find its footing at one point I
was wondering what this movie was really
about it's not until the last half when
the movie picks up a bit and you can
actually get into her plight and you
really do feel for her at least I did
there were times where I felt very
strongly for her and I wanted her to
succeed in her ideas but the first half
the movie is very scatterbrained and it
goes back and forth between showing what
her family life is
like then a past-life with her ex and
things that are meant to flesh her
character out but don't really feel like
they have a place in the film's story
and the story is a little messy because
it goes all over the place a lot but in
the end I did care enough about the
character of joy that I was rooting for
her and I wanted her to succeed so for
that reason despite some of the story
flaws and the fact that I didn't really
care too much about the characters
besides her I will give joy a b-minus
when you look at David O Russell's past
films that is a very disappointing grade
because I've pretty much loved his past
three movies and I hope that his next
movie is better guys 2015 has been
awesome I'm looking forward to bringing
you my lists for the best films of the
year and the worst films of the year I
already posted my review for Point Break
earlier this morning
it's Christmas I'm gonna take a break
thank you so much as always for watching
and if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes